good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
tuesday hope everyone is having a
fabulous beautiful day
it is like a chilly day here in new york
and it's getting me excited
for like sweater weather like chubby
girl weather like that is where i thrive
we're falling into fall i'm actually
wearing a sweater today i just jumped
right in because i saw i was 55 degrees
this morning
but i'm still wearing shorts because you
know i'm confused i um couldn't
have moved out of the shorts phase of
the year fast enough
i got a lot of comments about how like
still in the like dead of june and july
i was wearing jeans
um and it was mostly because i just
didn't want to wear shorts and like tan
my legs and shave my legs and just like
the responsibility
that comes with bearing legs um and as
soon as we got back i was the first to
put these jeans back on
you like jean weather legging weather
topshop stretchy jeans
oversized sweaters nothing like people
crave you know the christmas season like
they love that
i love the when the summer days like
slowly dwindle out and it's fully fall
and you can
get away with maybe like wearing a
windbreaker yeah i feel that i also feel
like this show is weather agnostic
like you could be watching any given
episode of our show and not know what
season it
is and i'm proud of us for that well yes
i think it's important that before you
comment about our outfits please
remember we're in an air-conditioned
unit like
while yes like sometimes it's not cool
enough no for sure but like well yes you
could judge our outfits based on the
weather outside
you could why don't you just trust that
we are doing the best things for
ourselves we're just like in a bubble
you know
what happens at the toast like has
nothing to do
with what's going on outside this is
really like a simulation in here it's
just it ain't real
yeah so i'm glad that we're just in
different
we're actually kind of in the same
season because like for me most like
this is jeans in a t-shirt weather
and but i don't [ __ ] with that so for me
it's like
i wear long on top short on bottom even
though i don't know what kind of legs i
think i have that i have to be burying
them all the time that's so funny
because my mantra is literally
shorts on top yep long on bottom yeah
but it's you know it's really the same
thing would you rather have
cold arms or cold legs for sure
yeah i don't know why i feel like the
world needs to see you might look cute
don't be
don't be embarrassed okay thanks you're
great i really miss theo today because
yesterday he hopped up on the couch but
right before he did like
he covered like a big chunk of thigh for
me oh yes
theo being on your couch is actually you
can use him to your advantage if you
want to strategically place him
to make yourself look cuter or just like
angle yourself it's actually a blessing
to have him here usually
it is but he has a big day today big day
getting his hair cut he
didn't get his hair cut the entire time
we were away his hair is like filled
with knots in his ears
we got out as many as we could but i'm
really grateful that his groomer's
coming today
and he's gonna smell so good and be so
fresh and so clean and i actually think
theo probably lost a few pounds while we
were away that's why it's so exciting i
was gonna say he definitely
shedded a few lbs while we were gone
because we were like so active
and like quarantine's been really hard
on like him specifically i'm not even
joking because he hasn't left his house
yeah he's just eating his feelings and
so he definitely
lost a few pounds like he was going on
hikes every single day but his hair grew
so much that i don't think you were able
to see
like a visually how much weight he lost
you weren't able to see like this felt
curve of his waist
right so the vet says that like the
proper um
like weight for theo's breed i don't
know if this is for every dog
it's like you shouldn't be able to see
their ribs but you should be able to
feel them and honestly his ribs were
getting like
harder and harder to feel recently so
after his journey um he went to like a
retreat like sonia morgan
um he's feeling and doing a lot better
thank you guys so much for asking
so i'm really excited i'm really i'm
excited to see him tomorrow
like with his new crop and it'll be hump
day
so oh perfect i'll be able to hum
someone you love and and that someone
you love will be looking good
i absolutely love to see it we have a
fabulous show for you guys i actually
watched so much tv last night
and everything i feel like um is worth
discussing sometimes i watch stuff and
like it's just not
i watched the parasol documentary which
was fascinating i
it's on my list it's the things to watch
i watch the extended cut version because
like when i searched into youtube it was
like do you want to watch the extended
cut or not
it's almost extended right yeah the more
the marriage i don't know what i saw
that wasn't in the original though
i also watched the social dilemma
actually i watched like 75
of it because towards the end it was
just giving me like such bad anxiety and
i watched dancing with the stars
great i watched love island still like
nothing to share and what's frustrating
is i'm now i'm like
six episodes behind but i can't like i
don't know what anyone else thinks about
these people because i won't go on
twitter because they're talking about
like six episodes ahead they're talking
about people who haven't even come to
the island yet
so i'm just like watching love island on
an island yeah that's annoying but um
the best part of watching a show like
when you're late is like the second you
catch up
is just like rolling over and like going
on instagram like following the people
on instagram
and you hesitate to do it when you're
catching up because you don't want to
accidentally spoil anything for yourself
so that moment when you can just like
finally go is the best i'm looking
forward to that for you yeah i've been
looking at their instagrams but i just
like scroll past the first six photos
really quickly like if they're in the
house or if they posted their goodbye or
farewell like i didn't see it
and they went like their post from
before the show which is also so
interesting and like everyone on the
show is an influencer model
etc and so that's how it should be yeah
it is how it should be
it's weird you know what is weird like
some of these especially the girls like
are really like instagram girls
and then you see them on tv and it's
like interesting to see what instagram
girls like look like off of instagram
yeah i mean that's like our whole
generation
you know but it's crazy because they
really like are that
supremely good looking oh that's good
you know yeah but it's like
oh like sometimes you see people on
instagram and you're like how is that
a person real and then you see them in
the real world like oh no you're like a
stunning person but you're a real person
right but you're also not like that real
like what you look like on instagram is
like slightly not what you look like
like filters slightly but there's no one
who's like
two different people well that's what
the social dilemma was teaching me it's
like
can you imagine being like a 13 year old
right now
no like no actually because you know
when you like
put your phone on you and you're about
to take a story like you literally can't
even look at your camera unless the
filter's on like i literally will not
look at if i'm on instagram stories
about to record a story i literally
won't look at my cell phone like until i
get to my coconut filter which is my
favorite
one yulia korres she makes facts she
makes the best ones
yeah um and it's like can you and like
it's funny like when we talk about
but can you imagine being like such an
impressionable 13 year old like having
that and you're wearing like
this the unrealistic standard of beauty
and then like you're also 13 and like
you can't look at yourself without a
filter
yeah i don't know i think it i i think
it's like
so damaging for sure but i think
sometimes like it swings both ways
because on the other hand like a 13 year
old girl
has people like when we were 13 we were
reading magazines where the covers were
like completely airbrushed and like
these were the only people that we had
to look up to and like we never even saw
a real photo of them
never really but like a 13 year old girl
like yes she does see the instagram
model and she sees herself and she can't
look at herself without a filter and
that's problematic
but she also has girls like emma
chamberlain who are like going on
instagram or youtube without makeup and
just being themselves and like so
and so it goes both ways but it is
extremely damaging well that's what the
documentary said they had all these like
silicon valley former silicon valley
people
who were like really there for the start
of like google and they were engineers
at facebook and twitter and pinterest
and they were and they said in the
beginning they're like we
ex like we knew that all the technology
we were creating could do so much good
we had no idea it was going to be doing
as much bad as it ended up doing and
like that's like
that's what it is it's like of course
it's honestly like think about like
think about any piece of media or like
anything it's like
our facebook groups like we started out
thinking
it'll just be so much good connecting
people around the world
literally turned into a [ __ ]
dumpster fire of [ __ ]
like and that really is like tech i
agree and i also
think as much as i'm trying to look on
the bright side i think when you weigh
all the pros and cons like which way
does the scale tip
i personally think it's more negative of
course
but you could also make the argument
technology yes it brought on a dumpster
fire of a facebook group
but it also saves lives like you know
people are doing like you always have
those microsoft commercials with what
they're doing with technology
and that is in the positive column
i mean i think like if if you needed
to be persuaded as to whether social
media has done more good than bad
literally like i think the most
interesting thing i learned from the
social dilemma is that like
after 2010 um self-inflicted harm
like hospital check-ins and suicide
attempt heart
uh check-ins from girls like age 12 to
16
literally quadrupled maybe it's like 180
up whoa so it's like how can you even
okay and like the whole movie was giving
me anxiety and then i was like you want
to check your phone i'm like yeah i do
check my phone and i always i'm like on
my phone while i'm watching tv and they
were like talking about it so i like
couldn't check my phone i didn't want to
like
let them win you know yeah so i'm just
like aware now but
i'm gonna watch that that sounds really
interesting it was very
um dense but here also one let's i guess
i'm not
recapping it in the tv recap but i just
wanted to talk about it
um the most interesting thing that i
thought and like
it's not like a revolutionary thing i
just had never thought of it before
facebook and like all these programs
they
are free to use right so you think that
you're a customer of facebook right um
sure yeah but you're not because you
don't pay
essentially the advertisers are the
customers are the customers and we
are the product because we're being sold
to advertisers
and did you know there's only two um
industries where the customers are
called the users
and it's drugs and social media oh my
god yeah [ __ ] like that is crazy yeah
because it's like we're addicted to
drugs
we're addicted to tech it makes you
think we are addicted to tech
i mean like the movie was like very do
they talk about privacy
have you been seeing those apple
commercials the new apple commercials
that are like
they're now selling that they're like
best for privacy so it's like people
like in random places
in the city just like sharing really
personal things about themselves that
they like looked up on their phone
they're like you know i ordered four
pregnancy tests and prenatal vitamins
it's like some things you don't want to
share with everyone right so now they're
like
it's funny how in order to buy a phone
now like
the most enticing thing is like how
secure it is
yeah i guess it was interesting
commercial it was a good
documentary i think you would enjoy it
okay check it out okay you guys would
enjoy it too
sweet maybe we'll like i'll talk about
it sometime this week exciting
so exciting okay um and the week before
it's a fabulous product i feel like
in quarantine times and just in this
life we're currently living in it's just
not normal and honestly um
i spoke with a lot of people whose feel
as though their mental health is not
being taken care of and it is the number
one priority
um so if you can't leave your house
right now or you don't want to leave
your house right now or you're just
having trouble
finding someone to talk to betterhelp
can help you out all from the comfort of
your own home
it's a service available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video
or phone sessions so you won't ever have
to sit in an uncomfortable waiting room
as with traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
you needed
when i started therapy a lot of people
told me that like sometimes the first
one doesn't hit and it's very normal
it's like shop for therapists so the
fact that they let you change it up for
free
is fabulous um better help is more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
they want you to start thriving and
living a happier life today
you can read all their fabulous reviews
on their website if you visit
betterhelp.com
toast that's betterhelp.com
toast and join the over a million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
so many people have been using better
health that they are recruit recruiting
additional
counselors in all 50 states so the
special offer for the morning toast to
get 10
off your first month of better help is
betterhelp.com
toast thank you better help for
sponsoring yes okay
first story of the day biggest story is
jerry harris from cheer the netflix
documentary
is under fbi investigation for allegedly
soliciting sex from minors
the fbi is investigating allegations
that celebrity cheerleader jerry harris
solicited sexually explicit photos and
sex from minors multiple sources told
usa today
agents executed a search warrant monday
afternoon at a home in naperville
illinois as part of that investigation
quote the fbi is conducting court
authorized law enforcement activity in
the area
siobhan johnson fbi special agent and
public affairs officer
told usa today she declined further
comment harris who gained national
prominence when he was featured in
netflix's cheer docu-series has not been
criminally charged
and he did not respond to a quest for a
request for comment the criminal
investigation is based on allegations
brought by 14 year old twin brothers
in interviews with usa today the boys
described a pattern of harassment
both online at cheer competitions that
started when they were 13 and harris was
19.
they said it continued for more than a
year those allegations were also
reported to police by varsity brands a
private company that dominates the
cheerleading industry
handling everything from uniform sales
to major competitions
harris is accused of asking one of the
brothers to have sex with him in 2019
at two varsity cheerleading competitions
in um on august 1st letters to i'm sorry
in august one letter to police in
florida and texas
varsity's chief legal officer burton
brillhart said the company had learned
of inappropriate sexual conduct
allegations against harris
and was reporting the information to
authorities as required by the law
i mean this is such a crazy story like
when i read the headline olivia sent to
me like
my jaw hit the floor um
this is so surprising this is so
surprising
i mean he hasn't been criminally charged
yet so we'll see what happens but
the fbi doesn't just you know no get
involved
on a whim no not at all and it's a
really really big deal it's just like
crazy
um but you know what i was actually
reading in toast after dark there was a
threat about it and there were a lot of
people who have been in the cheer world
and they said unfortunately like this is
some
this is a problem in the cheer world
like at like within squads and just in
the community
and they weren't surprised to hear about
it considering like the culture of
cheerleading which is just like
underscores this point that i feel like
we have to make more and more often on
the show which is that we need to be
protecting our young people
and we need to be creating safe spaces
and why is it that like these
these safe spaces for them which i would
think cheerleading these extracurricular
activities
gymnastics like that these are actually
the most unsafe places
for young people and that is just like
the hypocrisy of the world like the fact
that we carve out these
like sports are supposed to keep kids
out of trouble keep them safe keep them
healthy
and the fact that like these predators
just like inundate these types of
environments is why the world is so
[ __ ] up so [ __ ] up and like there's
just this undercurrent of
this like criminal activity against
children that happens in the world and
yes we talk about it and
and it's condemned but it's like i feel
like our like in this time in the world
in our generation like thinks they're so
like morally correct about everything
yet we like can't correct this and no
one really has even taken the time to
like
address it on a large scale you know i
mean i had no idea that like the
cheerleading
community had this issue um and maybe if
i had known that i wouldn't have been
like so
ambushed by this story i was ambushed by
it and then and then i read more and i
was like oh okay
i mean it's just not that that makes it
okay no it just goes to show you that
like you literally don't know anyone and
like
i mean jerry was like a breakout star i
mean all the kids were but jerry was
really like a fan favorite
a fan favorite for his positivity he had
been through so much in his life
um and now unfortunately
it's gonna be a no for me jerry yeah
this is really bad like
really upsetting yeah and
we'll keep you posted yeah i feel like
the fbi has some
loose ends that i need them to tie up
for me like whatever happened with jake
paul i was thinking about that too
like that was the biggest news ever he
was like apparently the biggest drug
dealer in l.a
wait that's what happened no that's what
like the rumors were like underground
twitter
it's crazy that we never even like at
least with jerry it's not like we just
got pictures of the fbi leaving his
house like
being like what's going on with jake
paul we never really got
what they went in for no we know they
like weapons that makes me feel like
it's part of like a much bigger state
yeah
maybe we'll find out in like a few years
in a netflix documentary yeah called
cheers
okay um we'll keep you posted on that
story but that was just like the most
shocking the most
like weird like what yeah the most
confusing shocking surprising
yeah okay next story some insider t
maybe
or maybe not true but like i just like
theorizing about what happened with
keeping up with the kardashians
okay khloe kardashian and scott disick
wanted to continue keeping up for an
easy payday
members of the kardashian family were
divided over whether to end the family's
iconic reality show page six is told
sources say that there were two camps
with kim kanye kendall and kylie on one
side
and chloe and scott on the other side
what about all the other ones chris
i think she goes with the flow yeah some
of them needed the money more than
others said an insider this sort this
article is like a little shady like was
it from
um page six like saying that chloe and
scott's businesses are like small
peanuts compared to kylie and kim and
kanye but
not is it a fair assessment not untrue
but um this is what i thought was
interesting the source
uh echoed their report from last week
which said that the family would likely
have continued with the show
were not for the harsh financial
realities of cable tv during the global
financial crisis
if it wasn't for the pandemic it could
have kept going said an insider
but times are changing and budgets are
lower and people want to move on
so it's like crazy to think that maybe
corona ended the
kardashian that is crazy to think i feel
like iteration i feel like it definitely
could have had something to do with it
while certain businesses like
direct-to-consumer brands have thrived
during um
quarantine like i feel like skims is
probably doing really well kylie
cosmetics is probably doing really well
i don't know how good like nordstrom
retailers are doing and i don't know how
good good americans doing
i feel like was actually might be a
brand that would have thrived for sure
and
their shirts sort of went viral those
please wash your hands yes and it's just
like cute i mean it's
way too expensive but it's cute
loungewear so like i don't know why
scott would need the money but
it it does make sense these two separate
camps of people
who would continue doing it for and
really what i consider to be an unfair
payday and those who wouldn't yeah it
it does make sense but i also feel like
for them it was like this is an easy
payday they have the formula they have
like the
the way that it goes and whatever they
do next it's going to have to be bigger
and better and
and a little different yeah you know so
it's the devil you know versus the devil
you don't i actually have a hard time
believing that kim was on the side of
not wanting to do it because even though
it's probably not their most lucrative
venture
um it's always kind of been this like
staple of their brand and
they're like a marvel like how do these
you know women get so successful
and it's been like this very um specific
formula over the years and that show was
an integral part
of their success and i think kim always
like honored that and respected that
and even though it like i said it might
not have been like their biggest
money maker i think that i don't know i
have a hard time believing kim
like i understand why kylie and kendall
wouldn't want to do it they weren't
raised on it
they're really not even a part of it
right now they're so busy um
but i don't know i don't see kim being
totally against renewing it
unless like everyone was on board yeah
no i i could see that too but i also
think like she knows that there's
much bigger money out there money so
just makes you think it's just i just
can't believe we're living in a world
like a post-keeping up world yeah i mean
it's not poached because we still get
two more seasons but like now that we
know
that's out of the bag honestly like of
all the [ __ ] 20 20 is thrown in us and
every time like something crazy happens
people are like 20 20.
i honestly thought like this was the
craziest
i couldn't believe it it makes so much
sense to me like
i just now that obviously i didn't
expect it to happen but once it happened
i was like oh yeah
of course yeah yes but i just never
thought we would get to a place
yeah i kind of always thought that it
was so cool
that they had gotten from season one to
season 20 like
literally be become the biggest
most famous stars in the world and they
always did this show and i was just like
i love them
yeah i don't know times are a change and
also i do think that like this pandemic
has
like hit e the hardest no i also think
this pandemic has like changed people
forever
and i feel like whereas maybe like the
article said like before coronavirus
like from an emotional standpoint they
never would have let go of the show
but now it's like things are just
different yeah things are just different
we know what's important and maybe money
is just important to them yeah
i think that it is in paris hilton
documentary i really learned that money
is really important to her
like she literally like does so many
things that make her unhappy only
because they give her money and like
she had a goal of making 100 million
dollars and she did it and now her goal
is a billion dollars and she's like i
literally will not get married and have
kids until i make a billion dollars
oh my god is she close she didn't like
give us like details i was like how
close are we like halfway there i was
just curious
um and she didn't divulge that
information but kim was in the
documentary for like a second okay i'm
so i'm gonna watch that today that's my
going to be my activity today i'm very
excited
okay next up speaking of money this
one's just all about
cash money liam mcsweeney this episode i
mean
liam mcsweeney is being stiffed by bravo
for season two an insider says
the newest member of rouhoni liam
mcsweeney may only be a one-season
wonder if bravo doesn't
cough up more cash an insider close to
the show confirmed to the post
the breakout star and fan favorite of
season 12 is being offered a quote
pathetically low pay raise
to appear on the next season of the
reality franchise and will have to say
sayonara to the series
if she isn't offered a more respectable
sum the source said bravo and mcsweeney
have not responded
um to their requests for comment um mick
sweeney along with most other first-time
housewives made about three thousand
dollars per episode
was so low which totaled in 60 000 for
the season tmz reports
the housewife believes bravo is
attempting to similarly lowball her with
the season 13 offer
the source confirmed probably like five
thousand dollars an episode sure
um i mean the fact that bravo pays like
first-time housewives and just like
thereafter like that amount of money is
crazy i don't think it's a slight
against
leah in any way at the end of the day
yes she was a total fan favorite shook
up the cast
but she still only has one season under
her belt and like that's how it works
so i don't think she's getting a
particularly low deal for her
i just think this is how bravo
structures their pay yeah and while that
may be
problematic i think it would be a huge
mistake for leah to walk away because as
much as housewives of new york
needs leah leah needs the housewives of
new york and i don't think she's gonna
walk away but i do think she's in a
position to get
much more money this is kind of
reminding me of like sports and like
her first season was top-notch like
tom brady and tom brady deserves more
money
and you know what like maybe this pay is
good enough for cindy bar shop
but like different strokes for different
houses i've been like and then bravo has
and bravo has made that distinction
denise richards four million dollars for
two seasons and i'm not saying that leah
is any no not in any way comparable to
denise richards but they pay based on
talent
no they don't everything the difference
between sports
and bravo here is that no unless you are
already a celebrity like liam mcsweeney
before this was not a famous person
so she i can't compare her to denise and
denise is
a part amongst a very elite group of
housewives
who don't need the show financially they
don't need it
famous like for their career the
difference between sports and housewives
is that
no matter who you are like or how much
money you have or how good you were that
season
you get a similar pay raise as your
co-workers like it's not actually based
on talent
no but i think that different housewives
negotiate different pay
of course but i think like the the cap
that bravo's allowed to go for like a
first-time housewife to the second
it's not based on well she was amazing
this season and let's say there was
another new york housewife and they both
wanted raises
i don't think that bravo would give leah
one more i think that they would
i don't i think it has nothing i think
like if you're asked back
it has really nothing to do with like
talent no
i think that it does and i think that it
should and i don't think that there are
any rules
in place that would stop it and there's
no like salary cap and if they
because we know that they pay certain
people more than they pay other people
and i actually think that
at least the vanderpump's height of her
emilia she's making a million a season
she's been on the exact same time as
kyle
is kyle making a millionaire i think
probably close then but it's never been
reported that that's the case and also
lisa rina like once alluded to the fact
that because vanderpump was getting paid
so much more than them
she should be bringing more to the show
that same point wasn't made about kyle
well maybe people thought that kyle was
bringing to the show because kyle was
the one who like
literally started the lvp teardown yeah
i don't know i just i think that if any
housewife deserves a big jump from
season one to season two it's leah like
every single person would tell you that
she had the best first season of
of any housewife really anywhere and
from what we understand and what
everyone's suggesting like
this next season will be built around
her
and that person deserves a raise i don't
know at the end of the day like i i kind
of agree with you but i also don't agree
with you at all like at the end of the
day like
yes she had a great first season and and
yeah but she's
us it's now on her second season and
she's still a regular housewife and
they're still ogs like
i don't know i feel like why is leah
different than any other housewife who's
ever gotten renewed for a second season
to read like you know what i mean
well not durie but like cindy barshop no
durie because she was just a new house
but like tariq didn't have a great first
season so like i honestly
think that she took this this menial
raise and probably was like thank you
for having me back
i feel like dorit didn't have a great
first season but really contributed to
like the ethos
and the the fights and all that stuff
but like no one was like angling for her
to come back
i mean i'm trying to think of who is
okay erica jane
very similar okay so that's a great
first season yeah
to and so i and she came on the same
time as kathryn edwards and say
katherine edwards had been asked back
for a second season
you think they should have been making
the same yeah they did the same amount
of work
i don't think so did you do this i think
you get paid based on
what you bring to the table and if the
show can like live without you i don't
think
rouhony whatsoever can live without leah
right now okay a different
scenario is with erica jane we never
heard a story like this
no so like she obviously took what they
gave her or like negotiated herself like
as good of a deal as she could
and recognize that not only like it's
really not about how much you get paid
to be on housewives like i feel like a
lot of the women
actually make more money outside of the
show than they do from the show but they
couldn't get those outside deals
without the deals yeah but without being
on bravo definitely someone like leah
makes could
be making more money from like
endorsements outside the show when she's
making 60 000
from the show but like lisa vanderpump i
think she did like teeny blends once
but was making a million dollars a
season that's real money
yeah but see the difference is that like
lisa vanderpump didn't need insta
like instagram sponsorships like
something i i disagree with that
well at the time i actually think right
now like her empire
restaurant business like actually might
be starting to crumble oh yes because
it's a difficult time to be in the
restaurant business but i actually mean
like before
kovid like there's just something fishy
about it no i think we're fine like
she's always been rich and i
like i feel like we can't compare her to
leah because like we've seen leah's
apartment like we know that leah is not
as financially
stable as lisa vanderpump and leah could
actually really use the money from the
show within the outside endorsements
where it's like
lisa vanderpump works on the show she
deserves to be paid like whatever but
she doesn't need
like instagram sponsorships you know
what i mean yeah
i just think that like sports housewives
should be paid
based on talent and based on like how
much
you bring to the show yeah you know what
it is it's like talent
in sports can be measured like in
touchdowns you know what i mean like
there are numbers
i don't know how you score okay i don't
really know how you measure housewives
quote-unquote
talent because it's all technically all
subjective whereas like sports is not
how many points did you score so i feel
like it might be
like a dangerous precedent and then you
like you already when you create a house
dangerous precedent was set with denise
for me like four million dollars for two
seasons
someone who has never even been on the
show and and so he actually does
have a a legitimate career being famous
and so
has the most to lose and it's probably
gonna play it
closest to the best like for me that was
when i was like oh
there's no status quo oh i disagree i
feel like
if anything it proved that like why she
got paid so much like she
you have denise richards is a household
name at this point in time and
especially before her first season
lee mcsweeney was not a household name
like it makes so much sense why liam
mcsweeney was getting three thousand
dollars an episode
and denise richards who literally is one
of the most famous people in the world
got four million dollars for two seasons
like it just makes sense i
it that does make sense but i think when
it comes down to it it's like
what the show would be without this
person
you know and like i think i just think
leah brought like made this
she made this season of new york 100 now
she will like the next season of new
york is gonna be like
so much about her she's she's
instrumental to the future of the
franchise
i think she deserves more money by the
way i think she deserves more money too
and i'm almost 100 sure like this was a
very strategical tactic by her team
planting this article
that we would talk about it today
putting pressure on bravo like
it's all strategic and she deserves a
raise a hundred percent
but i just think like to come out with
like i don't know what she's asking for
but like i hope she doesn't
overplay her hand like yes you're very
well liked
and everyone loves you i agree everyone
loves you you're very well liked you
brought a lot to the table but at the
end of the day
you're a second season housewife on a
very low brow franchise like recognize
that that's what all i'm saying
and don't throw it all away and don't
over play your hand but also know your
value no you're worth it yes 100
she definitely deserves a raise okay so
she deserves more than the
than the pathetically quote low grades
well i don't know what do they consider
pathetically low but let's say she went
from three thousand dollars an episode
to five thousand dollars an episode
which actually sounds like a lot but it
sounds like almost double yeah sure
but fine i think leah mcsweeney should
be making somewhere between seven to ten
thousand dollars an episode i do
and i don't think that's an unreasonable
request to ask bravo i don't know if
that's what she's asking for
or if she's asking for like twenty
thousand dollars an episode you like
technically yes
know your value but also know how
corporate works like you don't go from
three thousand dollars an episode to 50.
you go from like three to ten maybe i
don't know if you became the ceo
and like what was during the making just
give her her paycheck that's true i
wonder if they're going to replace
dorinda
you should be able to make the amount
that the person you pumped off made
yes because if they're they should treat
it like sports with a salary cap like
okay we have
five million dollars a season for roney
and that would force the women to like
perform yes oh my god we need every
franchise to have a gm
we actually jackie just made me watch a
draft day so like this is what i know
about
i love draft day so we should have
literally every hospital franchise
draft day 100 have a gm a salary cap
so they have x amount of money to give
and then it like instills a sort of
competition right and not only that it's
like you don't just show up and get paid
like you
you earn what you're worth and like how
did you perform last season
that might affect your next season like
i don't think anyone should get like a
pay cut
but without just being demoted or fired
but
i think that it might affect your raise
if like hey you didn't really bring that
much to the season yeah though there's
only four real
housewives of new york so they all
brought 25 percent no it's insane how
few housewives there are
i do think they have to replace there's
a lot of rumors that this woman rachel
something
um is gonna be the tiger tiger woods is
ex-mistress
yes is gonna be on it um but then she
was on
juicy scoop yeah and i think she said
that they had wanted her in the past but
i don't think there's any truth to the
rumors that she's gonna be on now so she
just seems like someone who literally
places herself in page six like
had one had literally one skype call
with rahone five years ago and like
literally can't get over it i'm dude
that's the vibe that i'm getting like
she's constantly being like why is
everyone asking me that's been like
she's the one who called page six that's
just the vibe that i'm getting
um i don't think anyone realistically
thinks that she's going to be on it and
i looked at her instagram and like she
just doesn't look like she lives a
luxurious life
yeah that's a big problem for you yeah
it's the only thing that matters to me
like
to me it's like if you are super wealthy
and like bring a level of class elegance
planes cars
to a show um that's valuable that's
really really valuable to me like sudden
like sutton i think sometimes thank you
for your plan because like the thing
that's most interesting about her and
this isn't to like
bash her at all like her wealth is so
interesting and her standard of living
and like when lisa reynolds got on the
airplane
to new york i was like freaking out
about being on a private plane and
sutton was like it's a flight to new
york like what's the big deal like that
is what we need yeah or like when sutton
like couldn't go with the ladies to
rome for some reason she was just like
oh so we'll get a plane
yeah no that's the level of like
thinking and the level of planning that
i
live for in a housewife and i know i
focus so much on money when it comes to
housewives but to me it's so important
and i feel like it's what started out as
an aspirational show for wealthy women
has really kind of turned in certain
franchises
to foreclosures rental apartments like
there's nothing wrong with those things
but it's just not what i want to see on
my aspirational tv show yes
i agree i'm sorry if i talk about it so
much but i think it's so important
to the quality keeping the integrity of
the brand i really do
and what it started out as like also
real housewives of orange county like
was supposed to be called behind the
gates like there
is an implied level of wealth and half
of them don't even live in gate
and like the price tags at the bottom of
the show like that's not interesting
when it's like
oh kyle went shopping at fendi and spent
two hundred dollars
yeah no but she spent five thousand
thousand right yeah
um oh also just a side note denise
richards is leaving beverly hills
and it turns out that money like
that she's not getting paid enough to
stay and that's why she's leaving
right so i'm that's where on the street
is that um the word on the street i feel
like
denise probably did ask for an insanely
unreal unreasonable raise
because that's what she thinks she needs
to stay around this time like she had a
terrible season she's like
i'll say give me 10 million dollars like
and i thought she was going to leave
even before i found out it was a money
thing and so i'm sure she tried to say
yeah maybe i would potentially do it if
you literally triple my salary yeah
it makes sense yeah like i guess she
doesn't need this but i mean four
million dollars for two seasons like
nice work if you can get it yeah no
honestly i keep thinking about it in the
framework of sports and it's
really interesting and and we never get
like answers on housewives like did they
quit
did they get fired what happened with
the money what did he want what did he
get
whereas like everything with sports is
public like got a 60 million dollar
contract got fired got traded
and i wish they would kind of emulate
that because it adds another level of
being a fan it's like
ben not only watches football but he
watches the draft and he's like oh they
got traded you know like
it adds like such a fun element and i
actually think like if housewives were
structured like that
where every player was like an agent
free agent two contracts like it would
be so
interesting yes because also like there
is a a similarity between like
what housewives are for for fans of
housewives to what sports are
for sports fans yeah you know like this
like competitive
you know we need like a fantasy league
draft day
situation yeah it all comes back to
drafting always
okay next one you know what anything can
happen on draft day
any that's the thing about draft day
anything can happen you think
something's gonna happen
but it could be anything yeah a little
morning show news or
posting news sorry drew barrymore's new
show
is um premiering on monday and she says
the rule book is on fire
so i saw some people i haven't seen much
but i did see some people on twitter
like tearing it up
well it hasn't even premiered yet but i
also did see a clip from it
i saw a clip she brought out lucy lou
and i would absolutely love to see it in
tune with what's necessary
majorly majorly but in august 2019 drew
barrymore shot an audition tape for a
hope for talk show in front of a live
studio audience
13 months in one pandemic later the drew
barry moore show premieres monday with
barrymore taking center stage in her
studio
and interacting with a virtual audience
oh
i thought she sits behind a desk that
says drew's news so i thought the name
of the show was going to be
drew's news and um i thought that was
really cute it's the drew barrymore it's
the drew barrymore
um i don't know this is interesting i
feel like celebrity talk shows are
a really funny and like fickle thing and
it's
so hard to get it right and people who
you think are gonna like become stars
christian or bethany like
don't work out and those that you may
maybe have have underestimated kelly
clarkson shine so i don't know i mean
when i heard it i'm like this is a good
idea she has a great name the drew
barrymore show like it sounds good
but you just never know i don't know
what contributes to like a great
celebrity
talk show um and you can't predict who's
gonna rise and who's
gonna fall so i wish her the best i just
don't know i wish her the best i
actually
think yes there is this untangible
factor that contributes to a successful
celebrity
talk show i don't know what it is and i
think that perhaps drew barrymore like
could have that factor but i think this
is maybe like the worst time to
have be launching a talk show yeah cable
is not at its best cable's not at its
best like people
aren't really watching tv and the tv
that they're watching like
when it's you know virtual filming or at
home or like a virtual studio audience
like
it's weird there is this [ __ ] truck
outside that keeps backing up me me
me me and like honestly i'm having
phantom sounds i'm gonna hear it in my
sleep and like i
just want to go outside and literally
drive the truck like to
jersey sorry what were you saying there
is this intangible thing
yes i don't know i it's like a it's a
balance of like charisma
uniqueness relatability yes um
i don't know and then there's just x you
know yeah it's
it's a medley and by the way tire is a
success it was on for so many seasons
but
at a certain point like shows just end
and so it's not like it's not chris it's
not bethany
no no i would consider tyra success oh
right you said chris and bethany i think
chris and bethany
um like meredith vieira like you would
think that would be a hit she was like
on people's
sh in people she was in people's homes
on the today show or whatever
whichever one she was on and it seemed
like a very natural progression and like
to me when that
failed i'm like that's a shock there is
a huge difference though between reading
from a teleprompter
and like being in a living room setting
making people feel like you're in their
home it's also a strange balance to be a
famous person
but have to give the floor to famous
people like most of being a talk show
house is actually not talking it's
listening so
it's listening to celebrities and like
blowing smoke up their ass
whereas like you're used to people doing
that to you yeah and you're the biggest
star where it's like you actually have
to take a step back when you become a
talk show host
and give the floor to someone else yeah
and i feel like a lot of people
maybe even like chris jenner can't do
that because they
are the star of their own lives and i
feel like it actually takes a very
humble person to be a good celebrity
talk show host because you have to
realize
immediately that it's not about you yeah
and i feel like
drew barrymore is a good listener yeah i
don't know like where i would get that
information it's just a vibe i get i
agree and i think kelly clarkson has
proved
you know time after time to be an
excellent listener yeah like whatever
she's doing over there
it's just electric it's so crazy i mean
i knew it like
literally four years ago when someone
was like who's your dream guest on the
show and i was like callie clarkson
it's because she is just hosting
material
and also like if you would have told me
two years ago that like in 2020 like
we're gonna have a brand new kelly
clarkson like
new show new life like new man she looks
so good
like if you had told me we were
literally gonna get a brand new kelly
clarkson like kelly 2.0 i never would
have believed you
i would have we get a new kelly every
four years think about it it's like a
president think about it
it's also it's really like her albums
like each album is so different from the
last and then she puts out a new album
she's like
this is how i'm this is fine the album
that like is all me
yeah nope like record label telling you
what to do i'm like
i thought that was piece by piece yeah
it's it's this one love so soft well
ellie times
did a huge piece on her i don't know if
you saw it just about like the new kelly
basically what we're saying
and she did reveal that she's working on
her latest album and her most personal
work yet
so they're all but like i truly believe
like it's not like miley where it's like
this is me yeah yeah every four years
she's a new person and we're getting the
most personal work yet
i actually think like her most personal
work ever was piece by piece
but that's not what she considers the
most personal work that's crazy she's
still like and i feel like
because of the way that she came up in
the industry like she always just thinks
that like
she has something to prove yeah because
she had like really bad like record
label drama back in the day with like
behind these hazel eyes and like even
though obviously that's such a
successful
song and time in her career like she
doesn't look back on it fondly i think
and so she's always i feel like she's
always looking at her past like through
a negative lens honestly we need a kelly
clarkson documentary
we do i feel like she's very interesting
i know and like she just posted the
other day because it's the anniversary
of her
winning american idol and it's like
that's the craziest thing
right all but you know but you know what
it also tells you like as much as it's
like wow american idol did this
no the cream always rises a hundred
percent there have been so many stars
from american idol and some of them have
literally gone on to be
kelly clarkson carrie underwood like
grammy jennifer hudson jennifer hudson
and some of them were just not david
uh archuleta yeah some of them were not
creamy
not everyone can be adultery no
not another one could be katherine
mcphee no oh my god
success i love her okay fifth and final
story that will
segue into our tv recap the family of
carol baskin's missing ex-husband
airs an ad during dancing with the stars
okay so
um actually i watched dancing with the
stars
live with commercials because you didn't
want to miss because i wanted to see the
commercial and i never saw it so
i think it might have been like a
regional commercial or like some tv
providers like you don't get the same
commercials
if i'm watching on spectrum in new york
and someone in la is watching i'm like
optimum like we are not getting the same
commercials no you're not and like
even in new york sometimes you're not
getting the same commercials it is crazy
also her ex-husband was a millionaire
yeah like that's why she was able to she
built this like huge cat sanctuary in
her like backyard in florida
because she was like a
wealthy widow oh got it okay i'm
learning something new every day yeah so
basically the family of
the her ex-husband who was the one she
allegedly was involved in
don lewis don lewis um they put together
an ad
uh to play during uh right before her
dance
which um basically just said like our
dad is missing
um um the hundred thousand dollars to
anyone who
has tips on whatever like we're just
trying to bring our dad home
it was so crazy really sad at the end of
the day it's like we're so caught up in
like this documentary and the memes and
tigers and carol baskin
killed her husband but you also forget
that like this family lost their dad and
like their ex-husband like it's really
sad
and this woman potentially lost her
husband
yeah sure carol baskin lost her husband
okay well i do think that that is so
interesting and like really um
a great use of ad space for this family
considering
what could potentially be the situation
and i'm sure they're just like done with
like the glorification
of who they think is a really bad person
totally
so i love them for getting in and like
maybe ruining her her night a little bit
did you hear
from them in the documentary yes and
they believe
that carol basking killed her husband
whacked him yeah and they give a plate
like convince them that it didn't
didn't happen literally they gave a play
by play of like the day that it happened
how like
she was so shady like locked herself in
his office like there was just like so
much going on
um but talking about dancing with the
stars i really do want to talk about it
because it was an interesting episode
two major um things happened before i
talk about the contestants just like
with the structure of the show
the first was that len who is the
judge the oldest one it's like stuck in
london i think with coronavirus he's
like a little too old to travel
so derek huff filled in for him and
honestly it was such a breath of fresh
air like he gave such
specific critiques he was like oh well i
think like your padaway was like you
know what i mean like
he didn't actually say potable right but
like it was just very specific critiques
not like
your energy was low or like your arms
weren't point like there was just
like real feedback and it was kind of
refreshing
and he's was such a big fan of so many
people that like before he even started
was like oh man i loved you in
you know and like it's nice when he
acknowledges the stardom so i thought
that was actually
a good thing and i think that he him and
julian should probably at some point be
transitioned
to full-time judges because like this
cast of losers that they have like is
so illusory sometimes the other one is
we've carrion and abba
yeah like i just i just can't and
bruno who i also just can't got it so
i think that i like the idea of pros
successful pros turning into judges i
like that too
so then the second major shake-up was
tyra banks and i was really really
excited because like
tyra banks has never put anything out
there like i didn't just absolutely love
like i just love her
um and i wanted to give her grace
because
you know going from a show that had two
iconic hosts like people loved something
to get fired or anything like
it was just time for a change they
didn't do anything wrong they went out
on top
to then take on the job by yourself and
have really big shoes to fill is really
hard and
she was really really nervous and then
on top given the fact that you have no
studio audience and they're playing a
laugh track that's like not timing with
your jokes
is tough that's rough so i want to say
that
there was like a very weird energy in
the ballroom last night like
an awkwardness um tyra was like very
rushed very nervous loved her words a
lot on the teleprompter
we have to give her was it live yes we
have i mean there's so much
they're all those pre-recorded packages
but the scoring the dancing and the
hosting we're live
okay um and we have to give her a little
bit of grace because like i said it's a
huge
transition transition but she does have
to get it together because it was
really bad um but like i love her and i
want it so badly to work and i don't
want
the fans to like regret or like i don't
want people to be like we should have
kept aaron and tom you know because like
she can do it i know she can yeah
yeah and she hosted this like we were
just talking about majorly successful
talk joe
she can do it but she was really nervous
okay i mean
it's a big shoes to fill i understand
being nervous it's like crazy to me like
i feel like tyra
is so much bigger and more prestigious
than dancing with the stars but like
even tyra gets nervous well she also was
the america's got talent host recently
and like really did a good job but i
don't think that show is majority live
so like
live is hard life is hard um now i want
to go through the dancers and tell you
what i thought of everyone because
aj mclean is so cute and i just like
love him and he was very good i mean he
has experience like dancing like boy
band dance
but he kept up and ever the thing is
like everyone was really good and there
wasn't like
a major like loser like sometimes
there's just someone who like has two
left feet
or is like two just can't get it now the
closest we got to someone who was the
major sink was christelle stouse from
you're lying i know it was really really
shocking she was on the bottom of the
leaderboard
stunk it up like she was just really not
good like she just doesn't have rhythm
she just doesn't have rhythm and she
doesn't have it
okay um but see speaking of someone who
might have it very shockingly was ann
heyche
she was excellent like she was funny and
i'm like who is this woman i had no idea
who she was
she's so familiar like she's from she's
from stuff and then she named all the
things she was from and i had never
heard of any of it but she had this
great energy and she was
funny like she was really being like a
character and then she danced
excellently
she reminds me of kate flannery from the
office last season who like
was this like random woman a little bit
older and then just like killed it and i
think she's going to be really really
good
uh speaking of stinkers as well kara
baskin like i couldn't
i couldn't actually watch it dancing
because like there was like so much
going on in my head but what i did watch
like it was atrocious like
she'll she won't get out for a while
because she's they were teasing the
whole time like
carol baskin care like she was like the
taylor swift like yeah she was crazy i
was like
how she's the most famous person there
but um she was an atrocious like an
actually horrendous dancer
i mean what did you expect charles
oakley was a
such a cutie also like athletes just
don't perform well most of the time
um it's really hard they are so
coordinated like in their field but
when it comes to dance like it just
doesn't click for them so charles oakley
wasn't an amazing um dancer but vernon
davis was an amazing dancer and i think
he might be single
and i think him and his partner like are
in love like i could just i was getting
that vibe okay
yeah um also someone who really really
shocked me
genie mai from the real she came out and
she was like i'm not gonna embarrass
myself and like i'm gonna kill it and
she really did
and she just was like so she's so pretty
and i
have i just like got watching her
package and then watching her dance like
i just had respect for her you know what
i mean like
i think like she didn't want to
embarrass herself and she like put in a
lot of time and effort and
it was good okay and like maybe you
wouldn't have looked at her before but
like she really made a name for herself
in the first round
wow now speaking of someone i respect
for gdm let's talk to someone who i have
literally no respect for jessie metcalf
i don't know why i came to this
realization when i was watching last
night i'm like i have no respect for you
and i don't know if it has to do with
the fact that like you hater you're a
cheater like you literally publicly
cheated on your
fiance of five years or like you threw
away a perfectly good career like
and i don't know what you did wrong but
like you just ruined it yeah you went
from desperate outside to literally a
movie that defined a generation
just john tucker must die to literally
being a hazmat to obscurity a matter
in a matter of years like it was crazy
so i don't know where my lack of respect
for him comes and then just like seeing
him on the show i was just like
i was like mad watching it i'm like no
no you don't get to be here like
it was just whatever he was a fine
dancer and honestly i don't even
remember watching him because he was
like he said desperate housewives was so
big for him
that it launched this amazing movie
career like implying that there was more
than one movie when you and i both know
very well that there wasn't no there was
not but you know what i'm just i'm going
to look up his imdb because now i'm
curious yeah no way
i'm curious how he can even say such a
thing yeah no john tucker must die like
i have to give it to him was huge oh
he's also like a hallmark
king okay so like i said yeah yeah it
was just one
right what was after john tucker must
die
he oh he's on chesapeake shores which is
a big hallmark show
so like okay it can be something that's
not hallmark okay okay um
something that you would would have
heard of i'm looking i really am
so like i said no respect for jessie
mchalf and the throwing away of a
perfectly good career
yeah no for real like there's nothing
maybe these are big like action movies
or something but nothing that we have
i feel like he like where he went wrong
is like it's so random i feel like maybe
he like pissed someone off and got like
black bald like that's the vibe that i'm
getting
right maybe he like cheated on someone
important right um okay johnny weir was
fine like honestly when you're a figure
skater like you have an unfair advantage
and he was like funny and sassy and like
obviously everyone loves him
i want to talk about justina machado you
might not have heard of her yes
i i know who she is she is like a da
she's like a soap actress she's like a
big abc star
but she also was in desperate housewives
and i couldn't
pin put my finger on why she looked so
familiar until i looked her up she was
on desperate housewives remember when
gabby's stepdad
um spoiler alert gets murdered by
everyone in the living room yeah
she is this stepdad's wife and comes
looking for him she's like alejandra was
just here
yeah so she what do you she's also on
queen of the south like she's a pretty
good character and
um i'm all caught up on it and she's
fabulous she was
amazing like i didn't know her and i
just left like literally her biggest fan
she had this energy and
she brought her latin flair and like i
was just liv like
literally living for her she's not my
number one favorite wow
um caitlyn bristow it was honestly like
emotional to watch
i was watching jason tardik filmed her
watching herself and
i was emotional so she got paired with
artem who was supposed to be your
partner five years ago so it's just like
this big full circle moment
and all this justice has been served and
for those who don't know because a lot
of people were like why'd you write
justice on your instagram
um caitlyn after she was the
bachelorette was the for actually like
one of the first
bachelor people to be offered dancing
with the stars and she was like ready
literally no the point is that she
wasn't like
sean lowe had done it chris soules had
done it and
all these men had done it right and then
caitlin was slated to do it and she is a
professional dancer and it was like
duh and mike fleiss who is the producer
of the bachelor like said he didn't want
you know people trying to get famous
from his show and forced abc to
fire her essentially that's so crazy
that she literally like had the job and
had a partner
and by the way what's most important is
that before she was on the bachelorette
she was a dancer yes
did they mention like mike fleisch in
her package no no so what did she say
happened
she didn't she didn't address that [ __ ]
she was supposed to be on the show oh in
her package no
but she did it on instagram that's the
most interesting part they have to
protect abc like
whatever mike fleisch is he does he even
still work on the bachelor i believe he
does doesn't he have all those like
charges against him that we reported a
while back
between his wife yeah um so obviously
just canceled culture like skipped over
mike place
um and carol baskin and all these other
people committed crimes yeah
right caitlyn bristow was obviously
excellent like she was
she's a dancer she looked great like she
was happy
like she was she's going to go far 100
yeah
someone who's also going to go far is
monica aldama
from cheer now it was a little weird
given the cheer news that came out
yesterday
but it's like those who can't do coach
you know those can't but she can do
and she was excellent she was at the top
of the leaderboard got like one of the
highest scores
um she's just like a lovely woman and
like someone i just
really like and respect and she got
respect and she was at the end which
means like she was important and
she was great like really really good is
that everyone no
there's four more people sorry three
more people nelly
is an absolute p john like i love him he
was great he danced to his own song
if you want to go and take a ride with
me but he did like a salsa and he was
like it was very confusing and weird
he did a great job um and i just like
loved him and something about him he was
giving me like cute boy vibes like i
just like had a crush on him
speaking of um cute boy but someone i
definitely do not have a crush on was
neve shulman
he is literally the biggest nerd of all
time um he was good
his partner literally called him a nerd
he was being like so nerdy like
literally he could not stop smiling like
and he's wearing a tuxedo so he just
like feels like it felt like a nerd yeah
um
again not someone i like love or care
about um but will do well
then the final person i want to talk
about is scott jackson
she's probably gonna win really yeah
like she was just giving it
all she's the youngest she has the most
energy she's tiny yeah he could flip her
around she was splitting in it was only
the first one
and she was at the top of the
leaderboard and she is um
someone i might not have you know uh
picked out as winner because she's so
young
but she is definitely forced to be
reckoned with on the dwts stage
so she was number one on the leaderboard
um she was up there i don't remember who
was number one towards the end but
it was her and caitlin was up there
and i don't know they rushed the end
because tyra banks was taking so long to
wrap up
interesting so it was enjoyable to watch
he'll continue watching the season
so now that you asked um i don't know
the two hours it literally felt like an
eternity
like this just the recap felt like an
eternity i know so i honestly don't know
if i'm gonna
make it the whole season i just wanted
to see everyone like yeah that's
exciting and you know what i appreciate
i like last season i i
enjoy watching it through your recap
yeah um
i also already recap the social dilemma
but uh the paris hilton documentary i
want you to watch it so i won't spoil
too much but all i have to say is
i absolutely love celebrity
documentaries like i first of all
be on whatever they're selling or trying
to tell me i love seeing how they live
how they travel like the logistics of
being a celebrity what the houses are
like how much staff they have
and paris was of course gave us
everything we needed and more with
she actually moved houses in the middle
of the documentary so it's like she went
from this like sickening house like this
more mature adult house
and you go from closet a to closet b and
just like seeing what it takes for her
to pack and like all this stuff right
now that gives me anxiety
yeah it was anxiety written and also how
she has insomnia
um and she's just like up all night like
and she's traveled to seal and like she
just like
she's just a very interesting girl not
only like
from the business side but this
documentary the whole point was for her
to
get away from his characters that she's
built dumb blonde simple life walmart
you know like all that stuff
um and let everyone know like she's
actually been in on secret for quite
some time and she but
she was so good at playing that
character like nobody believes that
she's anything
but that person and it's like trapped
her in this life where it's like
she's actually and they had nikki on it
um and actually someone who's spent time
with paris and nikki myself
i actually can attest to the fact that
like paris is nothing like that
character
and everyone who meets her is like she's
the smartest woman in the world but like
when celebrities say that you just like
don't listen
yeah um but she's the most normal like
down-to-earth like girl you would go to
college with like she's just like so fun
and funny
and she's very successful but she's like
stuck in this
like hamster wheel almost but the best
part of the documentary was
she got to play tomorrowland which like
for that's like when i play the vegan
theater like it's like the biggest deal
for a dj
and she was dating this guy and they had
met at ultra and they had like been
hanging out like over the course of the
documentary and
he came with her to tomorrowland and
like got wasted
and she was like not drinking she was
doing press and getting ready for her
set and she was on her laptop mixing
stuff because people think that she
doesn't do her own mixing because one
picture went viral
of some sound engineer turning up this
volume and literally was like look this
guy
paris has a djing for her so she takes
herself very very seriously and like
this is such a big day and it's such a
big deal
and this guy's getting wasted like
complaining that he's not hanging out
with her and like literally just like
slobbering all over her like kissing
kiss me paris is like [ __ ]
off and she literally kicks him out of
tomorrowland rips his bracelets off and
security is like pulling him out it was
the most
interesting thing he was literally like
ruining the most important day of her
life like she's walking to stage and
he's literally like
globbing onto her being like yeah hang
out he was jeremy like hang out with me
and literally she was like the [ __ ] off
me like it was it was
crazy like i couldn't believe that they
not only got that on film but they kept
it in the documentary it was
that is fascinating okay okay i need to
go home i need to go watch
it's such a good documentary i really
recommend it and i just love paris so
much and
kim was on there being like she
literally said like i wouldn't be
like who i am if it wasn't for paris
like paris
she didn't have to teach me anything i
literally just watched her and learned
everything it was crazy
so crazy okay i gotta go do you have
anything you want to recap
um no still nothing really major to say
about love island i don't know why
i'm still watching but you know i just
it's like hey i'm in like i just love
mindless [ __ ]
me too we actually haven't done a kmn in
a while but maybe there'll be something
mindless that shows up on your newsfeed
this week maybe i hope so
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning chose millennial morning
show where we post videos on youtube
monday friday 10 30 am eastern time so
if you're
no sorry thank you guys so much for
watching the morning toast the
millennium morning show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we are also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it's
apple itunes spotify all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning chosen leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
we love you guys very much we'll see you
tomorrow for home day goodbye
you